[Music]
this is uh this is philly d this is this
philly target
talking about the etiquette stuff it
would have been great if he was using
his hair product while he was doing it
oh hey guys just fixing up my hair a
little bit with my beautiful bastard
beard oil ah
anybody hear about this dead kid
[Laughter]
many of you have probably heard by now
um the news has spread really fast
because i think a lot of people were
waiting for for confirmation there was a
there's blades is coming out for a
nintendo switch
this fall what happened is that not the
news that's how that is that's a shame
by the name of etika
even even using kind of past tense is
new and weird by the name of etika who
um was there by the way the jump cut kid
can i point this out last night i don't
know if you were watching but we did a
uh
i did a a triple air horn every time he
johnny
said a lot
two minute 49 second video how many jump
cuts 25 jump cuts no
25
or 24 i'm sorry 24 jump 24 jump cuts in
this two minutes but hold on but wait a
second if you're making this is the
other thing if you're making a video
about somebody dying
you should have zero jump cuts
right my point last night okay well if
you're eulogizing somebody you should
have no joke two minute video it should
just be hey guys obviously you heard the
news uh we're all really broken up about
it right now so-and-so has passed away
don't really have all the information
right now uh we're gonna give his family
some privacy and some time
um but you know right now i think the
thing is to just try to remember this
person and honor their memory and i'll
keep you posted if the family has any
kind of fundraisers or anything god
bless and uh if you or somebody you know
is going through something like that
reach out to them be kind to each other
have a great night give the suicide
prevention hotline number at the end
bing bang bang you're done and it's done
yeah and it's just
24 jump cuts
found dead it's been confirmed by police
i i just watched it's like it's an
eight-minute video called i'm sorry that
i believe was on his channel at this
time it was removed other people have
re-uploaded it
um i will say having watched that video
even though i was not very familiar with
him i uh i couldn't help but really hear
and understand they don't stop it's the
best i was dying last night a vulnerable
place i wouldn't recommend so philip
defranco has
how many subscribers does he have
what's he up to
do we this isn't on his show i mean he's
i i don't remember because a lot yeah he
made it private why do people listen to
this guy
i'm really trying to understand like
what does he break he's the face
he is the face of
this new
fake
soft generation uh everybody just goes
oh my god
six million subs um sweetie oh baby i'm
so sorry you know what i mean like that
that fake and then as soon as you leave
the room they're like i don't like that
[ __ ] like it's just he he is
fakeness
just just crystallized just just come to
life and wait and like choose the form
of the destroyer if you were like i'm
going to choose a fake youtube
[ __ ]
we was wolf says he's the face of normie
youtube yeah yeah that that makes sense
yeah and all normies of chelsea pass now
and watching it it's it's really it's
kind of messed with my head today
although that's not though it's about
you hold on no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no sorry he's
messing his head up sorry sorry sorry
he's in a bad place dude
this is about you it is it's always
about him and you know we get again you
could too soon making fun of him at
least we're honest at least we're making
jokes this is in my opinion this is
scummier than any joke we made yesterday
because we were [ __ ] we were [ __ ]
around
these people that
[ __ ] it's about you know it took them
exactly 43 seconds
to make this about him it took 43
seconds mike
43 seconds to make this about him
yeah it is hey you know who's you know
who's headed actually mess with his
[ __ ] family who's dealing with it
stop pretending yeah you know what
else's head is messed with the one that
smacked into the east river yeah 30
miles an hour his head
messed with very bad
uh
i hate this guy
i think people really need to get the
full experience of philly d
and i think we need to full screen oh of
course dumb smug face sure uh just for
you know you want to smoke for yeah of
course okay i got you this one make sure
you guys
break enough rules here
although that's not the purpose of this
to make this in any way about me and
when i'm looking through this story i
can't i can't help but feel like this
was a person who who
when he said
when he just said
that is to make this to the whole
purpose is not to make this about me it
made it sound like he caught himself
watch watching a portion of what he was
saying
if you're in like a vulnerable place i
wouldn't recommend watching it it's it's
really it's kind of messed with my head
today although that's not although that
so he did a jump cut which means he made
it he made it seem like he said one
thing he would probably went on for
about 10 minutes about itself and you
know and it's like reminded me of a time
when i was going through and i was
petting my dog and i was like what's
this all really about man
what is life even about dude
shut up philly you [ __ ] fake loser
philip definitely reminds me of that kid
that would like take drama and pretend
to be
and you found out after high school that
he [ __ ] all these girls and you'd be
like wow guys
yeah nathan
i was the best didn't make this in any
way about me his name was jacob in our
high school but yeah everybody had one
everybody had one everybody had one i
had a [ __ ] jacob or nathan it was
just like yeah no totally i'll come to
the party
every one of them they would change in
front of them because they would have to
get in costumes and he just saw all of
them naked and then you don't realize
until you're like a grown man that it's
actually worse to be the kind of
emasculated person that can change in
front of
hmm
absolutely i want to feel like a man i
want a woman to feel legitimately
threatened around me if she's getting
the implication i just want but i want
him to know i'm a [ __ ] man i don't
have that titties i don't know if that's
the way you should say i want you women
to feel in danger when you're around me
i don't you're not me because you're in
danger when you're around it
sorry phil we're trying to before
merch does have a new pickup book coming
out called what are you going to do
about it
and which is the follow-up to how are
you going to stop me yeah
which is the part of the nobody's going
to believe you trilogy it really is it's
a great book i mean better than george
hbo optioned it yeah turns out stars
picked it up but still it's gonna be
good wait for the third chapter in this
saga
you know they don't even really test
those kits
so i mean
you know there's a bunch of those
rotting right now in the [ __ ] chicago
because they're just going to poke and
prod you and then never test my dna and
i'm going to walk so
do you want do you want waffle house or
not
do you want waffle house or not
it's not funny it's not funny and if you
or anybody you know uh
um
because they played a lot of nintendo i
wasn't too specific
i'm confused
i'm easily
all right sorry sorry hold on jump cut
today although that's not the purpose of
this to make this in any way about me
and when i'm looking through this story
i can't i can't help but feel like this
was a there's a person who
[Laughter]
in a crowded room you know what i mean
like a lot of us are like that
especially and it's just like it's a
supercharged situation when you have
people that are that are on camera or
have large audiences like for a lot of
people it can become very hard to tell
the difference between a cry for
attention right someone faking something
and a cry for help it feels like more
and more we're kind of trained to not
take things that we see online as
reality or serious where there's a
belief
you're not
could you let him finish being no no
who told him he was smart
because that's the pr i don't want to
punch him i want to punch anybody that
encouraged him and told philly defranco
that he was a smart man
this [ __ ] this like you know a lot of
people you just can't tell because shut
up philly [ __ ] stop i remember your
early videos it was you talking about
people pooping in bushes and [ __ ] while
you jump cut to other people pooping in
bushes stop [ __ ] now you're not this
[ __ ] spokesperson you idiot you ever
you you're uh
poop in a bush
no
you're not gonna like my show that
it's mostly that it's mostly poop poops
[Laughter]
because someone has a large audience
that
you know in some way they'll always be
okay because how can you really be in a
bad place right if you if you can do man
if only you had some sort of sponsor
that can help with that kind of stuff oh
dude trust me a lot of people have been
referencing it
a lot of people have been referencing it
if if only there was there is a rumor
and i have not confirmed this
yet but there was a rumor going around
that etika
we're shilling
better help no was it true or do we know
i i can't find you guys find out
find out we got people working on it
it's just um i don't think it's gonna i
don't think it's true somebody goes they
got a new sponsor
better jump there you go
somebody on uh
night wave chat last night said that
they probably should have gotten better
or help oh your best health best stuff
best more good or help
[Laughter]
all right so
d live chat at the back of the bus
they're going water's racist no i don't
i don't think it is that's how it worked
so now there's also colonel crunch goes
do you think philly killed him i don't
think philly killed him
how do you know he might have planned it
bum bum bum
we're kidding not about philly being
terrible he's terrible
a lot of what you want and you're eating
and sleeping well all right right right
right right right i want to sing colombo
to [ __ ] question this guy one more
question one more question mr defranco
hey
if you were sharing a better help
company uh
was the victim involved with this uh
better help scam with you oh and there's
one more thing do you own a
red rocket
company
oh no and they tried to run yeah he's
just run away
colombo never by the way the dude who
played what was it dudes who played
colombo uh
[ __ ] peter falk yes he never actually
did anything physical on that show so if
they ever ran it was he would always
stop him by like tripping him or
something really simple you know what
peter falk was really good in was the
movie made
when the movie made with uh jon favreau
vince vaughn yeah oh dude i haven't
thought about that by the way that come
out that movie's very underrated it's
it's not a great movie
but everybody in the movie is great i
don't know if that makes sense
you know what i mean it's like as a
movie you watch beginning and you're
like i've seen better movies and that's
genre 2001. that was a great movie and
people 2001
played the mafia boss
and uh i still remember when he's like
uh i don't understand man you got a
problem with me like you know i feel
like you don't like me and he's like
because you stole my [ __ ] carpet
cleaning van
i love that movie so hey philly sorry
you're boring philly jump cut
if that because someone has a large
audience that
you know in some way they'll always be
okay because how can you really be in a
bad place right if you can well i'll
tell you how if you invest all your
money in this thing called better help i
know i keep bringing it up but look guys
i'm in a bad place right now i'm not
gonna lie to you i love this
face that you just by the way
worst faces
not a pleasant looking man um he looks
like
he looks like seth macfarlane
who was the one
that always fought kirby the frog with
the sledgehammer they're always fun
kirby
do a lot of what you want and you're
eating and sleeping well but right
someone having an audience that's just
that's a spotlight right a spotlight
doesn't hug back and i wish that there
was something in this video did he just
say
a spotlight doesn't no no no no no no
did he just say the spotlight doesn't
hug you back man did he just say
a spotlight doesn't hug back yes he did
say that why do you people listen to
this man because he's awesome is it his
beard gel he's awesome
you're just a hater dude i could say
that like in any way would make anything
better right now in this moment for the
people that are impacted by this
you know what you think making this
video is going to make anything better
no sir like you know you think you're
helping
did you do you the change in the world
be be the change in the world you want
to see
thank you rachel
even though you look totally different
than you did in the last movie
yo ugly i don't feel as bad about you
dying if you're maggie gyllenhaal don't
get me wrong
you're still [ __ ]
but you're way less hot that you wear
the fast movies
to the greatest degree to the to the
slightly disconnected
place but the closest thing i have for
that is sending my my love and my
thoughts and my well wishes to those
impacted by this and of course a
reminder everyone everyone's saying it
but it's really
it really does need to be talked about
that if you seek help you are not weak
you are deserving of love if you feel
like you need a redemption for the
chance to change the chance to do better
even though a lot of the time when you
have success you feel even worse even
even guiltier for feeling
horrible and that can make you feel
ungrateful but we're all human the way
that i
and am cut stuff just and he connects
things that aren't connect you know what
i mean like we're all just human beings
man
do you understand somebody died and you
had the time to go cut
cut
whoop cut cut
dude you couldn't has he ever made a
video and i mean this i'm asking
seriously has he ever made a video even
one minute long where there's not a jump
cut
no he's he's
mr jump cut it's consistent right cannot
formulate us he's not good at making
sentences
and he was on rogan did you hear when he
was on rogan
he was on rogan
he's a stupid person like he's not in
any way capable of having high level
conversation i believe it he's not a
he's just some idiot that went to
[ __ ]
i think he went to uh i think he's from
tampa actually really i think he's from
tampa and he actually like i think he
went to like ecw
ecw he was in ecw
paul heyman
he's the paul heyman guy i didn't know
that
i often think about the world as we're
all different kinds of broken and we all
just we have varying levels of how well
we shield it yeah i guess if there is a
way that i i end this it's if you are
someone that that needs help i'm going
to link down to resources down below
this is something that i wanted to to
say it didn't it didn't feel right to
include it in the philip defranco show
it was already done there was a sponsor
i didn't want to make money from this
yeah that's where i'll well no no no no
no no no no did you see that did you see
that yeah i don't want to make money
dude this isn't about money it felt
weird to include this include this in
the show that's going to be watched way
more than that you know what i mean it
was it wasn't fair no no no no no no
what you did is you didn't want to sully
your philip defranco show with a dead
kid that's what it was they all got to
be uplifting and like can you believe
this guys oh my god have you seen this
that's that's all you're [ __ ] that's
all your dumb videos are
your videos are like when you hang out
with that guy that knows way too much
information who's always just [ __ ]
telling you something over and you know
what i mean when you ask hey did you
actually you know what it does he's like
philly defranco is everybody you talk to
at a comic con so like in episode 355
did you see that remember that guy
i don't understand how six million
people other than he was one of the
early youtubers i guess that's pretty
much it i think a couple people just got
in early and and
pretty much grew with the site you know
what i mean someone just said but
spotlights don't hug back royce i know
they don't
everybody knows they don't i
don't like this and there's a lot of
youtubers out there there's a [ __ ]
lot of you phonies out there that are
latching onto this specifically for
views
that's all it is it's all videos you
don't know him you don't know him
a guy died you saw him trending on
twitter and you said god damn it i gotta
get out there and get these clicks
everybody's talking about it this is a
business
yeah exactly and they don't like each
other this [ __ ] this they're trying
to sell you that all these youtubers
like each other the [ __ ] they do they
don't do you think if and we never would
obviously we'll be deleted but you think
it's some sort of alternate timeline if
we had a [ __ ] million subscribers
all of the sudden people would like us
no they wouldn't they would just go like
get some views off of these guys that's
what it is that's how it is